chloé n'a que 18 ans et pourtant elle
compte déjà à son actif une
participation à objectif top chef ainsi
qu'une victoire à la finale régionale du
championnat de france du dessert 2022
dans la catégorie junior le 17 février
dernier les candidats devaient réaliser
en trois heures un dessert à l'assiette
pour 10 personnes sur la thématique de
l'expression de soi dans mon dessert on
peut retrouver à imprimer sésame noir
une pâte sucrée sésame noir une
chantilly au lait ribot un servait alors
anges des suprêmes d'orange
une tuile au sésame noir un crime sa
mort avec une marmelade d'orange
l'intérieur et un shell citron puis
super content d'avoir gagné la finale
régionale je m'attendais pas du tout
faire des courses travail j'aime bien
parce que ça permet de de faire quelque
chose des différentes du service et de
ce qu'on fait au quotidien et ça permet
aussi de se comparer aux autres si un
peu de voir où est ce qu'on demandait et
tous actuellement élève au lycée
hôtelier de saint quentin en yvelines à
guyancourt elle est aussi apprentis au
restaurant étoilé la table du 11 à
versailles depuis quatre ans c'est un
dessert pomme sellerie donc on
retrouvera une brunoise de pommes et de
pommes granny smith et de céleri branche
une nuit lalanne est
avec un vinaigre de sa part réduit pour
faire une petite vinaigrette pour
assaisonner on retrouvera aussi un
biscuit au basilic 1 bis q chambre aide
au basilic un cerbère aux herbes
fraîches sur le dessus on aura un siphon
site rover basilique poudre d'estragon
et hino palin
grâce à sa victoire chloé s'est qualifié
pour la finale nationale face à six
autres candidats elle devra refaire son
dessert mais aussi un dessert surprise
avec des techniques imposées le tout en
quatre heures 50 pour la finale
nationale on se prépare dès qu'on peut
parce que ça va être une épreuve qui va
durer quatre heures 50 falloir sortir de
désert ça va être long gagner le
concours national ce serait incroyable
quand même ça m'apporterait beaucoup de
connaissances je pense qu'il y aura
beaucoup de portes qui sauvèrent à moi
quand même et j'espère le gagner une
finale qui se déroulera les 5 et 6 avril
prochain au lycée hôtelier bonneveine à
marseille